in march 2020 one man began
memorializing people who died from covid
on the twitter account faces of covet is
what he called it his name is alex
goldstein and he's paid tribute to
thousands of people
every day he highlights five or six
stories in a conversation
with our lead national correspondent
david bagno he explained why these
tributes are so very important to family
members who have lost loved ones and are
so meaningful to him as well
david good morning looking forward to
the story good morning my friend you
know one of the remarkable things about
alex goldstein is that he knows a little
bit about thousands of people's lives
he's been memorializing covet victims
online nearly every day for more than
two years in fact he said david the only
time i took a break was when my dad died
of prostate cancer
other than that he's done it every
single day
alex goldstein has waited nearly a year
and a half oh my god to meet karen
nassim benny in the flesh
how are you i'm okay how are you
i'm good better now for seeing you in
the flesh you know i spent too long in
the making i've never met anybody
from faces of covet it's always just
been from behind the screen and so
you're the first person
i've actually met whose loved one was on
the platform you were just kidding micah
i know how lucky i feel honored
karen's late husband stephen richard a
kind funny gentle soul whose heart and
hands were always open to helping others
was memorialized on the faces of coveted
twitter account which was created by
goldstein
as a way to personalize the pandemic's
toll no one else has put
a face to these victims the way you have
otherwise they're just a number you've
brought humanity
to this god-awful pandemic
you tell me a little more about stephen
he was one in a million we had a mad
love affair you know for the 30 years
that we were together he was salt of the
earth he was a kayaker he was a
photographer and he was the type that
could be really invisible so he always
got the most poignant shots how did you
meet
we met through a mutual friend and i
looked at him and i thought oh my god
he's the boy next door this is the kind
of normal guy i should like
goldstein has featured more than seven
thousand stories on faces of covet i try
to
wake up each morning look at the
submissions that have come in from
family members do a bit of my own
research i've done it almost every
single day
since march 28 2020 it has
become
more of a
required ritual in my life than i think
i could have ever anticipated in many
posts it is the picture which gives him
pause
all that faces of kovid tries to do is
get folks to stop just for a minute and
bear witness and look at their faces and
say their names um
and create just a little space for them
i love this one this quote that the
family gave he was never one for
religiosity but he wanted you to know
that if you find him in heaven he will
gladly accept a good beer and a juicy
steak brazilian plays american food is
terrible i mean this is really
vulnerable stuff
you are opening up on the
most famously toxic platform in social
media you are putting your loved one out
there with a couple lines about who they
were and then you're holding your breath
to see what the world does with it
and the things that people share it just
always blows me away this is like a
digital cemetery
you just put some of the quotes that i
wish headstones had on them right
it's a it's a good way to put it
roughly 5 000 people saw the face of
linda benson of oklahoma city this was
one where the the photo hit me
just this kind of relaxed smile you talk
about what would you want on your
tombstone as a parent
my brother and i were raised and taught
by a wise lady and we are forever
grateful for her love she was a sweet
sensitive and encouraging person i mean
you know
what else could you want as your legacy
this one uh was particularly powerful
because so this is dr chandra
57 of ohio
he was a cardiologist
and
i had found his story
through a news article
and his son reached out and saw it on
faces of covid and said can i add some
words what were the words his son wanted
to add he said that dr chandra was a
fierce advocate for his patients and for
the health of his community he spent his
life educating others on preventative
medicine
caretaking
to him was not a profession but a
calling he approached everyone as equals
with kindness and love he is remembered
fondly by his community one that
stretches three continents
the 38 year old goldstein who spent his
late 20s as a press secretary for a
former massachusetts governor
sees the faces of covid twitter account
as a first draft of history this history
is unfolding right now as we speak you
feel protective about it oh yeah
i feel a responsibility to make sure
that these people are treated with
dignity and respect i heard someone say
over the course of the pandemic in
speaking about someone who died of covet
may their memory be a blessing
you are preserving memories
i'm trying
um
it is too easy
in this pandemic if it hasn't happened
to you to look the other way
and we need to be uncomfortable and
vulnerable enough to sit with it and to
look at it and to say the names and look
at the pictures i know how hard it is i
feel it every morning
but the alternative
it's not acceptable
what has been the impact of this twitter
account you know what i hope the the
impact of faces of covet has been is
to restore
some semblance of empathy into how we
see each other anyone can come here
and say goodbye and
watch a bunch of strangers
participate in that with them and i
think there's meaning in that i hope
there's meaning in that
all those faces and so many more
you know one story we didn't highlight
was this there was a woman who reached
out to alex saying that she was thinking
about her dad hysterically as she termed
it one night and so she just googled his
name just to see what she might find
and sure enough up popped her dad
the daughter told alex seeing that tweet
with his name in his face made me feel
like there was someone out there that
would help me
feel like my dad is not just a number
you honored our pain
she said
yes that's the power of this skill yes
you did that and so did he i like may
their memory be a blessing you know
what's interesting to me when you lose
someone you love most people think well
i won't bring it up because it's
uncomfortable but people actually want
to talk about their loved ones they want
to share that with you and why they
meant so much that's why i love what
he's doing and i love that you brought
this story to us david bagnell
thank you and remember gail there were
times in the pandemic where a tweet was
sometimes the only way that someone
could actually have the public celebrate
their loved one because you couldn't
hold a funeral that's right
i do remember and you can't turn away
thank you david becknow we'll be right
back